Now to recap, we are
checking if some number
N is prime by doing
a trial division.
Here is the square root
of N. And here is 3.
Starting at 3 and we are
hopping along by 2 up
until the square root of N.
And at each point in the way,
checking if that number
divides N. So far,
people have been trying to
reduce the number of steps
we take, by perhaps, starting
later and taking larger steps.
Now I just want to pause here.
And let's think about what
is the ideal case for trial
division algorithm.
What is the best
we could possibly
do if we got very
creative in our stepping?
Well remember, any number N
has some prime factorization.
And let's say the square
root of N is here.
We actually only need to
step on prime numbers.
That would be the
best we could do.
Because we know if we
step only on primes,
we will eventually
find a factor,
a prime factor if
it's a composite.
The question now is how
efficient is this method?
Because it seems like we
have a perfect solution now.
If we wrote a new algorithm,
which first just called
the sieve.
Let's say the new algorithm
calculating if N is prime.
It could call the
sieve and generate
a nice long list
of primes for us.
And then we would have
our trial division,
which would use
this list of primes.
So it could hop along
and hit only primes,
up until the square root
of N, wherever that is.
So what's wrong with this?
Well, we can visualize
the time complexity,
or the number of steps taken.
And remember I did so by,
I coded up this algorithm.
And I put in a step
counter inside each loop.
So we have, let's just say, step
plus plus, means step plus 1
here.
And inside this other loop,
there's also a step counter.
Step plus plus.
So these are all
constant operations
checking if and marking.
So we just have a step
counter inside each loop.
And now, here is a comparison.
On the far left is our
old trial division method.
In the middle is our algorithm,
just calling the sieve
to generate all primes
up to N. And on the right
is this proposal
where we just call
the sieve to generate primes
up to the square root of N.
And then call trial division
just on those primes.
And let's see what
happens with small input.
As we can see initially,
the sieve takes many steps.
So even the modified
version on the right
is actually slower
than trial division.
And as the input grows, the
number of steps in the sieve
grows even faster.
So let's just forget the middle
and compare trial division
versus the sieve up to
the square root of N
plus trial division.
And here we can see
the old trial division
method is much more efficient.
The number of steps in our sieve
to square root of N, plus trial
division is growing much faster.
So it is actually
not an improvement.
And below is the program I
used to do this comparison.
And there is a recording
explaining how I set it up.
But now you may be
wondering, well,
what if we calculated
the primes in advance?
So the first step
would be to, let's say,
build an array of primes and
store it on a hard drive.
And then our algorithm would
just do trial division.
And it would know how
to hop on primes only,
because it would be reading
from this proposed prime list.
And perhaps our
prime list stores
all primes up to 20
digits, or even 100 digits.
Why can't we do this?
Well, the problem is
limitations in memory.
When we enumerate
lists of numbers,
which we'll explore next.
And just for example, let's
say we were doing this by hand.
We calculate 5 was prime.
We write 5 on a piece
of paper and we store it
in a filing cabinet.
Then we get 7.
We store that in
a filing cabinet.
9, or 11-- sorry-- into
the filing cabinet,
and then we have a filing
cabinet full of prime numbers.
This is our, think of
it as a prime array.
Now how big would this
filing cabinet be, if say,
we wanted all primes
up to 20 digits,
or all primes up
to 100 digits long?
Could we even store this
array on a hard drive?
And to understand why this
actually isn't possible,
we have to dive a little
deeper into how large does this
actually grow, this prime array?
And what is the size limitation
of modern-day and even future
computer hardware?